This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantan. Earlier this month, a man named Brian Chesky sent out an email that began like this. At the heart of our mission, he wrote, is the idea that people are fundamentally good and every community is a place where you can belong. Chesky is the CEO and co-founder of Airbnb, the online marketplace that connects travelers with people looking to rent their homes. Chesky's email, Center Users Across the Globe, was a response to concerns about racial bias.
这里是《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。本月初，一位名叫布莱恩·切斯基的男士发出了一封邮件，开头是这样写的：他写道，我们使命的核心理念是，人们本质上是善良的，每个社区都是你可以归属的地方。切斯基是Airbnb的首席执行官兼联合创始人，这是一个连接旅行者和房屋出租者的在线市场。切斯基的邮件《全球用户中心》是对种族偏见担忧的回应。
Some guests say they've experienced prejudice while trying to book rooms on Airbnb. We first explored these complaints in the spring in an episode titled Airbnb Wild Black. Today we're going to bring you that episode again with a few updates to reflect changes the company says it's making. We'll begin not with Airbnb, but with another online platform you may have heard of, Facebook. So a few months back, I was on Facebook when a friend request came in. I don't have a great memory for faces and names, so I found myself trying to figure out if I had met this person somewhere. But then, at the back of my mind, I remembered a study.
一些房客表示，他们在Airbnb上预订房间时曾遭遇过偏见。我们曾在春季的一期名为《Airbnb与黑人》的节目中首次探讨了这些投诉。今天，我们将再次为您带来那期节目，并附上一些更新，以反映该公司声称正在做出的改变。我们不从Airbnb开始，而是从你可能听说过的另一个在线平台——Facebook开始。几个月前，我正在使用Facebook时收到了一条好友请求。我对人脸和名字的记忆力不太好，所以我当时在想，我是否在什么地方见过这个人。但随后，我脑海中浮现出了一项研究。
It said my friendship choices on Facebook might be shaped by biases outside of my conscious awareness. Michelle Hebel is a psychologist at Rice University who ran the Facebook study. She designed fictitious Facebook profiles for two men and two women. Both men were named Michael Davis, both women were Jennifer Davis. All the characters were African-American. The only real difference between the profiles were the photos. One Photoshop version of Michael Davis and Jennifer Davis had lighter skin, the other Photoshop
研究称，我在Facebook上的好友选择可能受到我意识之外的偏见影响。米歇尔·赫贝尔是莱斯大学的一位心理学家，她主持了这项Facebook研究。她为两名男性和两名女性设计了虚构的Facebook个人资料。两名男性的名字都叫迈克尔·戴维斯，两名女性的名字都叫詹妮弗·戴维斯。所有角色都是非裔美国人。这些资料之间唯一的真正区别是照片。迈克尔·戴维斯和詹妮弗·戴维斯的一个PS版本肤色较浅，另一个PS版本
version had lighter skin, the other Photoshop version had darker skin. Mickey Hebel sent out friend requests on behalf of these fictitious characters to more than a thousand people in a big American city. Since these were invented characters, most of the requests were declined. But there was a big disparity in how often whites accepted friend requests from the darker skin, Michaels and Jennifer's. This is a great disparity in how often whites accepted friend requests from the darker skin Michaels and Jennifer's.
肤色较深。米歇尔·赫贝尔代表这些虚构角色向美国某大城市的一千多人发送了好友请求。由于这些是虚构角色，大多数请求都被拒绝了。但在白人接受肤色较深的迈克尔和詹妮弗的好友请求的频率上，存在巨大的差异。在白人接受肤色较深的迈克尔和詹妮弗的好友请求的频率上，存在巨大的差异。
People were less likely to friend them. They were less likely particularly to friend the dark black males. If you follow these kinds of experiments, this finding is disappointing, but not surprising. Using similar experimental methods, researchers have found disparities in the way professors spend time with students, how companies select job applicants for interviews, even how legislators respond to constituents. But something new is happening today.
人们加他们为好友的可能性较低。他们加深色皮肤的黑人男性为好友的可能性尤其低。如果你关注这类实验，这一发现令人失望，但并不令人惊讶。利用类似的实验方法，研究人员发现，教授在学生身上花费的时间、公司如何筛选求职者进行面试，甚至立法者如何回应选民，都存在差异。但今天发生了一些新的情况。
The bias decisions we once made in interpersonal settings are now being made on giant online platforms where our actions have the potential to affect many more people. and interpersonal settings are now being made on giant online platforms, where our actions have the potential to affect many more people. Think about the way you might look for a roommate. Once upon a time, you may have put up a flyer on a bulletin board and talk to people who responded. Today, you might turn to sites such as roommates.com or Craigslist.
我们曾经在人际交往中做出的偏见决策，现在正发生在巨大的在线平台上，我们的行为有可能影响更多的人。我们曾经在人际交往中做出的偏见决策，现在正发生在巨大的在线平台上，我们的行为有可能影响更多的人。想想你寻找室友的方式。曾几何时，你可能会在公告栏上贴传单，并与回应的人交谈。今天，你可能会转向roommates.com或Craigslist等网站。
Raj Goshaal, a sociologist at Gautier College in Baltimore, recently conducted a roommate study on Craigslist. Raj Gosha, a sociologist at Gautcher College in Baltimore, recently conducted a roommate study on Craigslist using a technique similar to the one Mickey Hebel used on Facebook. We definitely found a pattern of preference or bias in favor of white sounding names. So for every 100 replies that a white sounding name got a Latina name, got about 75, and an African-American name got about 65 or something like that. That is a huge difference. It's a pretty big difference, right? So if you're African-American,
巴尔的摩戈彻学院的社会学家拉杰·戈沙尔最近在Craigslist上进行了一项室友研究。巴尔的摩戈彻学院的社会学家拉杰·戈沙尔最近在Craigslist上使用了一种类似于米歇尔·赫贝尔在Facebook上使用的技术进行了室友研究。我们确实发现了一种偏向听起来像白人名字的偏好或偏见模式。因此，每100个回复中，听起来像白人的名字会得到回复，拉美裔名字大约得到75个，而非裔美国人的名字大约得到65个左右。这是一个巨大的差异。这是一个相当大的差异，对吧？所以如果你是非裔美国人，
you'd have to spend about one and a half times, as much time, applying for housing as when somebody with a white name. On today's podcast, we're going to delve into what happens when age-old biases rear their heads in a new and growing part of our lives. What sometimes called the sharing economy. It's one thing if I want to discriminate about who I'm going to have over on Friday night
你申请住房所需的时间大约是白人名字拥有者的1.5倍。在今天的播客中，我们将深入探讨当古老的偏见在我们生活的一个新的、不断增长的部分中抬头时会发生什么。这就是所谓的共享经济。如果我想在周五晚上歧视谁来我家做客，那是一回事
to have for dinner or who I want to have sleep over. But it's another thing when my private house starts to become my business. The sharing economy platforms that allow you to hail a taxi, call a babysitter, find a room on Airbnb, rely on making what used to be business exchanges into semi-personal transactions. Your Uber driver sees your name and photograph. You see your driver's name and photo. It's supposed to increase trust, and there's every reason to think it does. But it also does something else. When you give people names, then you give people information about your ethnicity. It's supposed to increase trust and there's every reason to think it does. But it also does something else. When you give people names, then you give people information about your ethnicity. You give people information that they can use to look you up and figure out more cues about you. And that becomes problematic.
或者我想让谁留宿，那是另一回事。但当我的私人住宅开始变成我的生意时，情况就不同了。那些允许你叫出租车、找保姆、在Airbnb上找房间的共享经济平台，依赖于将曾经的商业交换变成半个人化的交易。你的Uber司机能看到你的名字和照片。你能看到司机的名字和照片。这本应增加信任，而且有充分的理由认为它确实做到了。但它也做了别的事情。当你给人们名字时，你就给了人们关于你种族的信息。这本应增加信任，而且有充分的理由认为它确实做到了。但它也做了别的事情。当你给人们名字时，你就给了人们关于你种族的信息。你给了人们可以用来搜索你并找出更多关于你线索的信息。这变得很有问题。
Mickey was on a ship when I interviewed her. She's teaching at Semester at C. During the long voyage, she says, her students tell her about the many online platforms that they are using. There's a website called care.com. And it's a babysitting website where people advertise themselves as babysitters. And they have to put a picture of themselves on. So you can think about how, again, maybe I don't
我采访米歇尔时，她正在一艘船上。她在“海上学期”项目任教。她说，在漫长的航行中，她的学生告诉她他们正在使用的许多在线平台。有一个叫care.com的网站。这是一个保姆网站，人们在上面为自己做保姆广告。他们必须放上自己的照片。所以你可以想想，再一次，也许我不想
want a babysitter that is of that race. Maybe I don't want a babysitter that is of that race. Maybe I don't want a babysitter that is of that gender. And so you begin to see where this very subtle type of discrimination can be very systemic. The sharing economy is unleashing new possibilities in our lives. These platforms allow us to meet more people, visit more places, get more connected. I'm personally a fan of many apps. But it also seems clear to me that these platforms provide a mechanism to amplify our collective bias. What's especially insidious about the biases on these platforms is that their consequences are largely hidden.
要一个那个种族的保姆。也许我不想要一个那个种族的保姆。也许我不想要一个那个性别的保姆。于是你开始看到这种非常微妙的歧视是如何变得非常系统化的。共享经济正在释放我们生活中新的可能性。这些平台让我们能够结识更多的人，访问更多的地方，建立更多的联系。我个人是许多应用程序的粉丝。但对我来说，这些平台提供了一种放大我们集体偏见的机制，这一点也很清楚。这些平台上偏见最阴险的地方在于，它们的后果在很大程度上是隐藏的。
If your request to be a babysitter gets turned down, you have no way of knowing if this was driven by racial bias. So I asked Hidden Brain producers Maggie Pennman and Max Nestrak to take a few weeks and try to find people who were personally affected by such biases. They decided to focus on an important new part of the sharing economy, Airbnb. Imagine you're going on vacation with some friends. You do a quick search online, find a few hotels in the city you'd like to stay in. You pick one, ideally with a hot tub, and enter your credit card information. Great, you think.
如果你的保姆请求被拒绝，你无法知道这是否是由种族偏见驱动的。所以我请《Hidden Brain》的制作人玛吉·彭曼和马克斯·内斯特拉克花几周时间，试着找到那些受到此类偏见个人影响的人。他们决定专注于共享经济中一个重要的新部分：Airbnb。想象一下，你正和朋友去度假。你在网上快速搜索，在你想去的城市找到几家酒店。你选了一家，最好带热水浴缸，然后输入你的信用卡信息。太棒了，你心想。
I'll set. But then you get an email. We're sorry, but the dates you just booked aren't available after all. They're listed by mistake. Now, if this happened to you once, you might chalk it up to a weird website glitch. But if it happened to you over and over, something would start to feel funny. You might start to feel like it's something about you
我搞定了。但随后你收到了一封邮件。很抱歉，你刚才预订的日期其实没空。它们被错误地列出了。现在，如果这种情况发生在你身上一次，你可能会把它归结为网站的一个奇怪故障。但如果它反复发生在你身上，事情就会开始变得有点奇怪。你可能会开始觉得，是因为你自己的某些原因
that's making these hotels suddenly unavailable. This is exactly how Christina Crittenden felt when she would try to use Airbnb to book vacations with her friends. She would find a house that was listed as available, send a booking request. And I would get declined all the time. Kertina got a bunch of similar responses.
导致这些酒店突然无法预订。这正是克里斯蒂娜·克里滕登在尝试使用Airbnb与朋友预订假期时的感受。她会找到一间显示有空的房子，发送预订请求。而我总是被拒绝。克里斯蒂娜收到了很多类似的回复。
The host would always come up with excuses like, oh, someone actually just booked it. Or oh, some of my regulars are coming in town and they're going to stay there. I just haven't updated my calendar. But I got suspicious when I would check back like days later and see that those dates are still available.
房东总是会找借口，比如，哦，有人刚刚预订了。或者，哦，我的一些常客要来城里，他们要住在那儿。我只是还没更新我的日历。但我开始怀疑，因为我几天后再去查看，发现那些日期仍然显示有空。
Christina is black, and this is relevant because on Airbnb, both hosts and guests have their names and photos prominently displayed on their profiles. And this is actually one of the platform's selling points. It's supposed to make these transactions between strangers feel less anonymous and less scary. But it also makes Christina start to wonder if these rejections had something to do with her race. My name is Cortina. I have a very black sounding name, and I also had my photo, so I'm very clearly a black woman.
克里斯蒂娜是黑人，这一点很重要，因为在Airbnb上，房东和房客的名字和照片都会在个人资料中显眼地显示出来。这实际上是该平台的一个卖点。它本应让陌生人之间的这些交易感觉不那么匿名，也不那么可怕。但这也让克里斯蒂娜开始怀疑，这些拒绝是否与她的种族有关。我的名字是克里斯蒂娜。我有一个听起来非常黑人的名字，而且我也放了照片，所以我很明显是一个黑人女性。
And when she looked at the reviews that previous guests had left for these hosts, I never saw anybody who looked like me. So Cortina did what any good millennial does when they're frustrated. She took to Twitter. And I was just venting my frustrations and I just included a lot of screenshots of the messages that I was getting from people and I put the hashtag Airbnb wall black.
当她查看之前房客留给这些房东的评论时，我从来没见过长得像我的人。所以克里斯蒂娜做了任何一个千禧一代在沮丧时会做的事。她上了Twitter。我只是在发泄我的沮丧，我附上了很多我从人们那里收到的消息截图，并加上了标签“Airbnb与黑人”。
She started hearing from lots of friends with similar experiences. The most common response that I got was, oh yeah, that's why I don't use my photo. Like duh. Like I was the late one. And one friend who hadn't. One of my friends who was actually black, he responded to me and said, well, I've never had an issue.
她开始收到许多有类似经历的朋友的消息。我得到的最常见的回复是，哦，是的，这就是为什么我不放照片。就像“废话”。好像我是最后一个知道的。而我的一位朋友，他其实是黑人，他回复我说，嗯，我从来没遇到过问题。
And then he went back and checked his profile. And I guess he'd never want to use his photo. So he realized that the whole time he had been using a photo back and checked his profile and I guess he'd never want to use his photo so he realized that the whole time he had been using a photo of some random white guy from our school and so he's like oh maybe this is why I've never had an issue. So Koutina decided to tweak her profile. I shortened my name to Justina which is a name that I go by in work and in other settings. And I changed my photo to a landscape.
然后他回去检查了他的个人资料。我想他从来不想用他的照片。所以他意识到，一直以来他都在用一张照片，回去检查了他的个人资料，我想他从来不想用他的照片，所以他意识到，一直以来他都在用一张我们学校里某个随机白人男性的照片，所以他说，哦，也许这就是我从来没遇到过问题的原因。所以克里斯蒂娜决定调整她的个人资料。我把名字缩短为贾斯汀娜，这是我在工作和其他场合使用的名字。我把照片换成了一张风景照。
Ever since I changed my name and my photo, I've never had any issues on Airbnb. Now it's impossible to say exactly why Kertina was rejected by those specific hosts. But a recent study shows racial discrimination on Airbnb is widespread. I'm Michael Luka. I'm a faculty member at Harvard Business School. I'm an assistant professor of business administration. Michael Luka and his colleagues, Benjamin Adelman and Dan Sivirski,
自从我改了名字和照片后，我在Airbnb上就再也没遇到过任何问题。现在，很难确切地说为什么克里斯蒂娜会被那些特定的房东拒绝。但最近的一项研究表明，Airbnb上的种族歧视非常普遍。我是迈克尔·卢卡。我是哈佛商学院的教员。我是商业管理助理教授。迈克尔·卢卡和他的同事本杰明·阿德尔曼和丹·西维尔斯基，
sent out fake Airbnb requests to real-life hosts. So we sent out 6,400 requests to stay with people and we kept every request the same. The only thing that was different about the requests, the profiles attached them either had African- American sounding names or white sounding names. So like, does Brad get the same number of responses on Airbnb as Jamal? We could see that there was a very different response rate and acceptance rate for African American guests relative to white guests.
向现实生活中的房东发送了虚假的Airbnb请求。我们向人们发送了6400个住宿请求，我们保持每个请求都相同。请求中唯一的区别是，附带的个人资料要么有听起来像非裔美国人的名字，要么有听起来像白人的名字。所以，布拉德在Airbnb上收到的回复数量和贾马尔一样吗？我们可以看到，非裔美国房客相对于白人房客的回复率和接受率有很大不同。
Having an African American name leads to roughly a 15% lower chance of being accepted as a guest on Airbnb relative to having a distinctively white name holding all else constant. To put this in perspective, Airbnb isn't some little startup anymore. It's one of the largest players in the hotel industry worldwide. In 2015, more than 2 million listings were offered on the platform from hosts around the world. That's nearly four times as many rooms as the Married Hotel chain. You can even run to Castle.
在保持其他条件不变的情况下，拥有一个非裔美国人的名字导致在Airbnb上被接受为房客的机会比拥有一个明显的白人名字低约15%。从这个角度来看，Airbnb不再是一个小初创公司了。它是全球酒店业最大的参与者之一。2015年，全球房东在该平台上提供了超过200万个房源。这几乎是万豪酒店连锁店房间数量的四倍。你甚至可以租到城堡。
And it's not just vacation rentals. People are finding housing on this platform for months at a time. So discrimination on Airbnb is discrimination in the housing market. Michael Luka and his colleagues think people could be discriminating without even knowing it. Buying a lot of people is something that is accidental. What Michael Lucas is talking about is unconscious bias. These hidden associations we have that affect our behavior without us realizing it.
而且不仅仅是度假租赁。人们正在这个平台上寻找一次住上几个月的住房。因此，Airbnb上的歧视就是住房市场的歧视。迈克尔·卢卡和他的同事认为，人们可能在不知不觉中进行歧视。很多人购买东西是偶然的。迈克尔·卢卡所说的是无意识偏见。我们拥有的这些隐藏联想，在没有意识到的情况下影响了我们的行为。
It's unlikely that most hosts are saying to themselves, I'm going to reject this person because I don't want to write to a black person. I mean, maybe some people are intentionally discriminating. There are probably some people like that, but Michael Lucas suspects the way Airbnb's platform is designed is triggering the associations people have of some racial groups. So because names and photos are the first thing people see, it may also be one of the first things they consider consciously or unconsciously when choosing a place to stay. He and his colleagues looked at five major cities in the US, and discrimination was happening across the board.
大多数房东不太可能对自己说，我要拒绝这个人，因为我不想写给黑人。我的意思是，也许有些人是故意歧视的。可能确实有一些这样的人，但迈克尔·卢卡怀疑Airbnb平台的这种设计方式正在触发人们对某些种族群体的联想。因此，由于名字和照片是人们看到的第一件事，它也可能是人们在选择住宿地点时有意识或无意识考虑的第一件事。他和他的同事调查了美国五个主要城市，歧视现象普遍存在。
We saw that there is discrimination among cheap listings, expensive listings, in diverse neighborhoods, in homogenous neighborhoods, among white hosts, and among African American hosts. I actually spoke to Mike Luca last week. That's David King, the brand new director of diversity and belonging at Airbnb. He knows this is a problem, and he wants Airbnb to be a leader on fixing it.
我们看到，在廉价房源、昂贵房源、多元化社区、同质化社区、白人房东和非裔美国房东之间都存在歧视。我上周确实和迈克·卢卡谈过。那是大卫·金，Airbnb新任多元化与归属感总监。他知道这是一个问题，他希望Airbnb能成为解决这一问题的领导者。
There is a racial bias in platforms, and we are working with Mike Luca and any other external interested parties. And how do we address and fix this problem? David King also pointed out there's a lot of opportunity for Airbnb to do good. They're bringing together people from all different backgrounds who wouldn't normally meet. We've done some recent reports in Chicago and New York pointing out that underserved communities, especially African-American communities, have benefited quite a bit from our platform, usually in neighborhoods where there are few hotels.
平台中存在种族偏见，我们正在与迈克·卢卡和任何其他外部利益相关方合作。我们如何解决和修复这个问题？大卫·金还指出，Airbnb有很多做好事的机会。他们正在将来自不同背景、通常不会见面的人聚集在一起。我们最近在芝加哥和纽约发布了一些报告，指出服务不足的社区，尤其是非裔美国人社区，从我们的平台中受益匪浅，通常是在酒店很少的社区。
One of those neighborhoods with few hotels lies east of the Anacostia River in Washington, D.C. There are lots of big box stores and empty lots, but also row houses and families that go back generations. We went there to visit Airbnb host Sinta Keeling. Hi, how are you? Sinta owns a three-story townhouse in a new development. She rents out two rooms on Airbnb. There's a fitness room, cable and high-speed internet, solar panels, and slippers for all of her guests. I love the slippers, first of all. So, I do know.
其中一个酒店很少的社区位于华盛顿特区阿纳科斯蒂亚河以东。那里有很多大型超市和空地，但也有排屋和世代居住的家庭。我们去那里拜访了Airbnb房东辛塔·基林。你好，你好吗？辛塔在一个新开发区拥有一栋三层联排别墅。她在Airbnb上出租两个房间。那里有健身房、有线电视和高速互联网、太阳能电池板，还有为所有房客准备的拖鞋。首先，我喜欢这些拖鞋。所以，我知道。
Sinta is a super host, and we're not just saying that because of the slippers. It's an official designation she's earned from Airbnb. Based on positive reviews from her guests, her responsiveness to booking requests, and the fact that she's never canceled a booking. It shows Airbnb travelers should've been verified as a good person to stay with. Sintis says, as a black host in a black neighborhood, that's important. She feels like she gets held to a higher standard
辛塔是一位超级房东，我们这么说不仅仅是因为拖鞋。这是她从Airbnb获得的官方称号。基于房客的好评、她对预订请求的响应速度，以及她从未取消过预订的事实。这表明Airbnb旅行者应该被验证为一个好的住宿对象。辛塔说，作为一个黑人社区的黑人房东，这一点很重要。她觉得她受到了比其他房东更高的标准要求。
than other hosts. This neighborhood is called Capitol View, and it's 98% African-American, double digit unemployment. We asked Sintinta whether her race and the racial composition of her neighborhood made it harder to get gas. And she said, Absolutely.
这个社区叫国会景观，98%是非裔美国人，失业率达到两位数。我们问辛塔，她的种族和她所在社区的种族构成是否让她更难获得房客。她说，绝对是。
Yeah, no, I had one. I've had some instances where people ask me all these questions about it's unsafe. And I'll say, you know, I'm a black Filipino woman. I think we take great pride in our community. This is absolutely a good place for you to stay and I'll say those things and then they'll be crickets. They'll just not book." But Sinta also said there were great things about Airbnb. For one thing, it brings her a study
是的，不，我有过。我遇到过一些情况，人们问我所有关于它是否安全的问题。我会说，你知道，我是一个黑人菲律宾女性。我认为我们对我们的社区感到非常自豪。这绝对是一个适合你居住的好地方，我会说这些话，然后他们就会沉默。他们只是不预订。”但辛塔也说Airbnb有很多很棒的地方。首先，它给她带来了一份稳定的
second income. Airbnb brings business to the stores and restaurants that don't typically benefit from the tourism industry. Airbnb slogan is, belong anywhere. And there's some truth to it. S Cindy Keeling told us a story about one of her guests that drove this message home. He came back from being out for the day and told her, I took the bus back and I was the only white person on the bus. And it was all these black people. And I asked myself, were they going to hurt me? Am I unsafe? And then I realized they weren't hurting me.
第二收入。Airbnb为那些通常无法从旅游业中受益的商店和餐馆带来了生意。Airbnb的口号是“四海为家”。这其中有一些道理。辛塔·基林给我们讲了一个关于她的一位房客的故事，这个故事让这个信息深入人心。他从外面回来，告诉她：“我坐公交车回来，我是车上唯一的白人。车上全是黑人。我问自己，他们会伤害我吗？我不安全吗？然后我意识到他们并没有伤害我。”
And nothing was going to happen to me. Like they were just sitting there normal. And he was saying this in a way that he was like, he mentally realized the hardness of what he was saying with the same time he was just being honest about what he was like he mentally realized the horridness of what he was saying with the same time he was just being honest about what he was thinking and that he arrived at the stop and just said come off and like nothing had happened to him and it was just the shock. Since it's how she knows that some people won't rent from her because she's a black host
“什么事也没发生在我身上。他们只是坐在那里，很正常。”他以一种他精神上意识到他所说的话的恐怖，但同时他只是诚实地表达了他的想法的方式说出了这一点，他精神上意识到他所说的话的恐怖，但同时他只是诚实地表达了他的想法，他到达车站后就下车了，什么事也没发生在他身上，这只是震惊。辛塔知道有些人因为她是黑人房东而不会租她的房子
in a predominantly black neighborhood. But here's the thing, she's glad those people don't book with her. The strange thing about Airbnb makes it tough is I really don't want a racist gastin my house because I don't I live here in this space so I don't need to feel uncomfortable you know the other way but if if if you just feel like well you know maybe I'll give this a shot that I'm willing to be open-minded. feel like, well, you know, maybe I'll give this a shot that I'm willing to be open-minded. The fact is, Airbnb is not the same thing as a major hotel chain. Hosts have discretion on the platform, but guests don't have the same legal recourse as hotel customers if they feel they've been discriminated against.
在一个以黑人为主的社区。但问题是，她很高兴那些人没有预订她的房子。Airbnb奇怪的地方在于，它让事情变得艰难，因为我真的不想让一个种族主义者住在我的房子里，因为我住在这个空间里，所以我不需要感到不舒服，你知道，反过来也是一样，但如果你只是觉得，嗯，你知道，也许我会试一试，那么我愿意保持开放的心态。事实是，Airbnb与大型连锁酒店不同。房东在平台上拥有自由裁量权，但如果房客感到受到歧视，他们没有像酒店客户那样的法律追索权。
We spoke to a couple lawyers for this story, and the legal picture is a little murky here. It isn't clear who, if anyone, is liable for discrimination on a web-based platform. So Airbnb does offer this opportunity to experience different cultures to meet people you wouldn't normally meet. But sometimes, hidden biases getting in the way. And people like Kirtina and Sinta are paying the price. [♪ Music playing inman and Max Nestrak.
我们为这个故事采访了几位律师，法律情况在这里有点模糊。目前尚不清楚谁（如果有的话）应对基于网络的平台上的歧视负责。所以Airbnb确实提供了体验不同文化、结识你通常不会遇到的人的机会。但有时，隐藏的偏见会阻碍这一切。像克里斯蒂娜和辛塔这样的人正在付出代价。[♪ 音乐播放，玛吉·彭曼和马克斯·内斯特拉克。
When we come back, Maggie and I are going to talk about the steps Airbnb is taking to address these issues since our story first aired in April. Stay with us. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanthan. We're exploring the many ways in which the sharing economy might allow hidden biases to flourish. As apps in the sharing economy become an increasingly large part of our lives, they have the potential to create great disparities.
回来后，玛吉和我将讨论自我们的故事在四月首次播出以来，Airbnb为解决这些问题所采取的步骤。请继续关注。这里是《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。我们正在探索共享经济可能导致隐藏偏见滋生的多种方式。随着共享经济中的应用程序成为我们生活中越来越重要的一部分，它们有可能造成巨大的差异。
The latest twist on the age-old problem of cabs that don't stop to pick up black people. A lot has happened since our story first aired. The hashtag Croutina started Airbnb While Black when viral. News organizations all over the country picked up the story. Airbnb hired a team of heavy hitters to address these issues, including Laura Murphy of the ACLU and Eric Holder, the former Attorney General. They conducted a 90-day review to look at the problem and they've just released a report announcing changes based on their findings.
这是出租车不停车接载黑人这一古老问题的最新变体。自我们的故事首次播出以来，发生了很多事情。克里斯蒂娜发起的标签“Airbnb与黑人”在网上疯传。全国各地的媒体都报道了这个故事。Airbnb聘请了一个重量级团队来解决这些问题，包括美国公民自由联盟的劳拉·墨菲和前司法部长埃里克·霍尔德。他们进行了为期90天的审查来审视这个问题，并刚刚发布了一份报告，宣布根据他们的调查结果进行改革。
I'm in the studio now with Maggie Penman to talk a little bit about this issue and get an update on what Airbnb is doing. Hi Maggie. Hey Shankar. Back when we aired this episode, Maggie, Airbnb was already offering away for hosts and guests to get around possible prejudice. That's right. The platform has long offered this feature called Instant Book. And normally when you want to book a place on Airbnb, you have to put in a request and the host accepts or denies it. But with Instant Book,
我现在和玛吉·彭曼在演播室讨论这个问题，并了解Airbnb正在做什么的最新情况。你好，玛吉。嘿，尚卡尔。玛吉，当我们播出这期节目时，Airbnb已经在为房东和房客提供绕过可能存在的偏见的方法了。没错。该平台长期以来一直提供一种名为“即时预订”的功能。通常当你想要在Airbnb上预订房间时，你必须提交一个请求，然后房东接受或拒绝它。但有了即时预订，
you are accepted immediately. And one of the big changes that they just announced is the company is planning to make this feature much more widely available. Let me try and understand this. What would incentivize hosts to offer this option? Well, it's much more convenient for guests, so I think you're more likely to get your place booked. And it can also be more convenient for hosts. Let's say you're renting out your whole home. Instant book might just be easier for you. Max and I talked with someone who used this feature to circumvent what he saw as discrimination. Very much like Christina Crittenden, Reed Kennedy is African-American and he says he was having trouble getting his requests accepted.
你会立即被接受。他们刚刚宣布的重大变化之一是，该公司计划让这一功能更广泛地可用。让我试着理解一下。什么会激励房东提供这个选项？嗯，这对房客来说更方便，所以我认为你更有可能预订到房间。而且这对房东来说也更方便。假设你正在出租你的整个房子。即时预订可能对你来说更容易。马克斯和我与一位使用此功能来规避他所认为的歧视的人谈过。和克里斯蒂娜·克里滕登非常相似，里德·肯尼迪是非裔美国人，他说他在让自己的请求被接受方面遇到了困难。
And so after being rejected, I think in that case, four times within the same day for reasons again that weren't specified. I started to see a pattern. He complained to Airbnb and Airbnb gave him a credit. But of course, if your problem is that you are not able to book a place, getting a credit to book another place doesn't really help you very much. So he tried the instant book feature. And ironically, the host was a black man who may have been using the instant book feature for the same reason I was. Airbnb said in their statement that they hope to have a million listings available for instant book by January and they think this is going to start to address some of these problems. So in some ways this could be a design solution for the psychological problem of bias.
所以被拒绝后，我想在那一天内被拒绝了四次，原因同样没有说明。我开始看到一种模式。他向Airbnb投诉，Airbnb给了他一笔信用额度。但当然，如果你的问题是你无法预订房间，获得一笔信用额度去预订另一个房间并不能真正帮助你。所以他尝试了即时预订功能。讽刺的是，房东是一个黑人，他可能出于和我一样的原因使用了即时预订功能。Airbnb在声明中表示，他们希望到一月份有100万个房源可供即时预订，他们认为这将开始解决其中一些问题。所以在某种程度上，这可能是针对偏见心理问题的设计解决方案。
Right and this is similar to a solution Michael Luca came up with, that's the researcher at Harvard. He worked with a computer scientist to develop a Google Chrome plugin called Debiased Yourself. And it removes photos and names from people's profiles so users can't discriminate even by accident. He said he actually got this idea from Orkis Tres. It used to be that Orkis Tres were overwhelmingly male, and many people might have thought, oh well, maybe they're just more male musicians, or maybe they're just better than female musicians. But then this started to shift, and orchestra's became more and more gender-balanced. When a couple of researchers tried to figure out why, they found that many auditions had
没错，这类似于迈克尔·卢卡（哈佛大学的研究员）提出的解决方案。他与一位计算机科学家合作开发了一个名为“去偏见”的谷歌浏览器插件。它从人们的个人资料中删除了照片和名字，这样用户甚至不会偶然地进行歧视。他说他实际上是从管弦乐队那里得到的这个想法。过去，管弦乐队绝大多数是男性，许多人可能认为，哦，好吧，也许只是男性音乐家更多，或者也许他们只是比女性音乐家更好。但后来情况开始转变，管弦乐队变得越来越性别平衡。当几位研究人员试图找出原因时，他们发现许多试镜已经
switched to being blind, which meant judges had gone from watching the performers to just listening to them play from behind a screen. Mike Luka thinks that Airbnb should be doing the same thing on a larger scale. And this step of increasing Instant Book is sort of moving in that direction. One of the things that I love about the digital world is that it gives us the opportunity to choose exactly where to put screens and where not to put screens. So I think we have a host of new decisions that we can make as market designers that will decide how inclusive a society we have
转变为盲选，这意味着评委们不再观看表演者，而只是在屏幕后听他们演奏。迈克·卢卡认为Airbnb应该在更大范围内做同样的事情。而增加即时预订这一步在某种程度上正朝着这个方向发展。我喜欢数字世界的一点是，它让我们有机会选择确切地在哪里放置屏幕，在哪里不放置屏幕。所以我认为作为市场设计者，我们有一系列新的决策可以做出，这将决定我们拥有一个多么包容的社会，
or how much discrimination we want to encourage or allow. Here's the interesting thing Maggie, one of the attractive things about Airbnb and the sharing economy in general is that people don't feel like they're walking into an anonymous place. You know, they feel like they know the people with whom they're renting a home. So there's some balance between hiding information from people and revealing information that can exacerbate these biases. I remember talking to Raj Goshal, this is the sociologist who did the study looking at racial disparities in roommate searches. He told me that maybe the focus should be on playing up some kinds
或者我们想要鼓励或允许多少歧视。有趣的是，玛吉，Airbnb和整个共享经济吸引人的地方之一是，人们不觉得他们走进了一个匿名的地方。你知道，他们觉得他们认识那些他们租房的人。所以在向人们隐藏信息和揭示可能加剧这些偏见的信息之间存在某种平衡。我记得和拉杰·戈沙尔谈过，他是那位研究室友搜索中种族差异的社会学家。他告诉我，也许重点应该放在强调某些种类的
of information. Perhaps colleges and universities can play a role in this and perhaps websites like Craigslist or roommates.com could do more to actually like front load information about people's living habits or cultural identities, what time people get up and go to bed, what level of messy they are, that sort of thing. Rather than immediately hitting people over the head with somebody's name, just because all the evidence we have, evidence from other studies just suggests that race in names is such a powerful signal to people that we probably don't actually want it to be the first thing or the immediate thing that people see in our deciding by.
信息上。也许学院和大学可以在这方面发挥作用，也许像Craigslist或roommates.com这样的网站可以做更多的事情来真正地预先加载关于人们生活习惯或文化身份的信息，比如人们起床和睡觉的时间、他们有多乱，诸如此类的事情。而不是仅仅因为我们拥有的所有证据，来自其他研究的证据都表明种族在名字中对人们来说是一个如此强烈的信号，以至于我们可能并不真的希望它是人们在决定时看到的第一件事或直接看到的东西，就立刻给人们当头一棒。
That's a really interesting point. I think that's why Airbnb hasn't done what some people were suggesting, which was to totally eliminate names or photos, because that lack of anonymity is definitely part of the appeal. Is the company doing anything else to try and eliminate discrimination? Yeah, so in addition to building up that instant book option, they're also asking everyone who uses the platform to commit to a stronger, non-discrimination policy.
这是一个非常有趣的观点。我想这就是为什么Airbnb没有做一些人建议的事情，即完全消除名字或照片，因为那种缺乏匿名性绝对是吸引力的一部分。该公司还在做其他事情来试图消除歧视吗？是的，除了建立那个即时预订选项外，他们还要求每个使用该平台的人承诺遵守更严格的非歧视政策。
And they're working on an anti-biased training that's going to be offered on the site. But the most radical thing they're doing is implementing what they call an open doors policy. If any person anywhere in the world feels they can't get a booking because they're being discriminated against, Airbnb will find them a similar place to stay. If there isn't anything available on Airbnb, they'll find accommodation for the malware. So this is clearly an effort to address concerns
他们正在研究将在网站上提供的反偏见培训。但他们正在做的最激进的事情是实施他们所谓的“敞开大门”政策。如果世界上任何地方的任何人觉得他们因为受到歧视而无法预订，Airbnb将为他们找到一个类似的住宿地点。如果Airbnb上没有空房，他们会为他们找到其他住宿。所以这显然是解决担忧的努力
about discrimination, but a policy like this would really only help guests who are having trouble booking a room, not hosts who are trying to rent a room. The company said in the statement, this is the beginning, not the end of their effort to combat bias, so maybe in the coming months we'll see features or policies designed to help host too.
关于歧视，但这样的政策真的只能帮助那些在预订房间时遇到困难的房客，而不是那些试图出租房间的房东。该公司在声明中表示，这是他们打击偏见努力的开始，而不是结束，所以也许在未来几个月，我们会看到旨在帮助房东的功能或政策。
That's interesting. Thanks so much Maggie. Thanks Shankar. This episode of the Hidden Brain Podcast was produced by Maggie Penman and Max Nestrak. Our supervising producer is Tara Boyle. René Clare manages our Facebook and Twitter pages. Check out the hashtag, Cortina Started, Airbnb While Black. An incredible conversation has unfolded there over the last few months. I'm Shankar Vetantham Anthony and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这很有趣。非常感谢你，玛吉。谢谢，尚卡尔。本期《Hidden Brain》播客由玛吉·彭曼和马克斯·内斯特拉克制作。我们的监制是塔拉·博伊尔。雷内·克莱尔管理我们的Facebook和Twitter页面。查看标签“克里斯蒂娜发起的，Airbnb与黑人”。过去几个月里，那里展开了一场令人难以置信的对话。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这是NPR。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。